michelle bagbo son of former ivorian
president laurent bagbo
savers a win over a sitting cabinet
minister
his supporters are ecstatic about the
victory
aware of the tensions in the land
michelle one of the new faces in
parliament
says it's time the country heals
we are going to work on reconciliation
in the return of ivorians in exile
including my father that way democracy
in our country will be
strengthened reassuring words for
citizens
who feared the worst the opposition had
hoped for better results but given it
boycotted last year's presidential
election
some observers say the coalition
performed better than expected
under the law anyone not satisfied with
the provisional results can go to the
court in the next 72 hours
the result of the election gives
president alastain water
and the ruling rhtp party total
dominance
over ivory coast politics
the opposition pdci is a minor league
party that's ethnic based
it lacks national spread as for us it's
clear
we've won the parliamentary majority we
set out to achieve
election observers called the process
transparent despite incidents recorded
in some parts of the country
this is a really minor issue
compared to the world nation
that can affect you know the credibility
of this
election claims and counter claims of
victory by the leading political parties
nearly plunged the country into another
round of violence
businesses here in the economic capital
arizona remain open during
and after the announcement many here say
the country is pulled back from the
brink of another round
of post-election violence but they also
warned what political leaders say or do
in the next few days
will determine what happens next
the results will now go to the
constitutional court to decide in three
days
either to reject or validate the outcome
ahamadi ruiz al jazeera abijah